The other alternative, or
another big alternative,
is actually top Q-learning
which is what you described.
>> You basically take whichever thing
had the most associated with it.
>> The most value.
Okay, yeah.
Good.
>> The most value.
And that works pretty well, again those
are the kind of things that you would
probably come up with,
if you just spend a little bit of time.
Just say well what are the obvious
things that you could do,
both of those make sense.
It of course also has a problem and
that problem is that the agent,
well, there are several problems but
one that isn't necessarily obvious, is
the agent that happens to have given the
most Q-value to a particular action may
also give very nearly the same Q-value
to all the other actions as well.
So it doesn't actually
have a strong preference,
it just happens to put
high value on everything.
And so you're not really doing much for
it either.
Meanwhile, make every other agent might,
for example, like the second action.
For that particular agent.
And so it makes a lot more sense to take
the second action but you can't because
by a quirk of fate the other action
got slightly more value to it for
just that one agent.pericardial sac
>> So
it starts to feel a little
bit like a negotiation.
>> Right, which is why there's
something called negotiated W-learning.
>> [LAUGH] W-learning.
>> So,
this is a lot more complicated and
I can't write it down in just
a fancy little equation like that.
But what negotiated W-learning
basically boils down to is,
the agent with the most to loose gets
to figure out what the action is.
So you sort of minimize loss
rather than maximize an average or
pick the best thing.
So you look at the the subagent that,
basically what you do instead of looking
at the things that everyone thinks might
be good an average of them are doing a
max over them, if you look at the things
where the difference between
the maximum choice and
the minimum choice are really large and
let that agent make a decision.
And just sort of weighted
across all of the actions.
It can be arbitrarily complicated but
basically you don't want any agent to
lose as opposed to having agents win.
And all of these have their strings and
all these have their weaknesses And
they're all very kind of cool and
under different circumstances.
Greatest mass makes sense,
in other circumstances top makes sense,
and negotiated is good for
other situations.
And you can come up with
lots of other things,
the key thing is that you
need to do arbitration.
The problem with all of these though,
all of these methods and
any other methods that you come up with
is that they're terrible, and in fact,
They're impossible.
What does that mean, you say.
>> What does that mean?
>> I'm going to
summarize it simply this.
The very first example you gave,
you said, or
the very first response that you gave
to me when I described greatest mass
Q-learning is you said, what you're
really doing is you're voting.
>> And
voting is definitely not impossible.
But as you know,
there is an impossibility result for
voting and
that is arrows impossibility result.
And if you don't know what arrows
impossibility result is for voting,
then you need to stop what you're
doing right now and go look it up.